[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar characterization of lentiviral
vectors
using capillary electrophoresis platform
technology
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by psyx to learn more visit psyx.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
aaron shafer senior scientist in the
analytical methods development group
within the children's gmp at st jude
children's research hospital
erin you may now begin your presentation
well first of all i just want to thank
you for that brief introduction uh today
i will be talking about the
characterization of antiviral vectors
using capillary electrophoresis
as the platform technology
before i get going
or before we dig into the talk i did
want to give you a little background
uh
about or some some background about
saint g children's research hospital
which is where i work here i work
here at the children's gmp which is
actually part of the hospital itself
and you know the really the main mission
of our hospital is is finding cures to
to
treat kids to save children from
pediatric cancer so
uh the founder danny thomas a long time
ago said that no no child should die at
the dawn of life so
it's the kids that are in the hospital
that i see every day that really drive
our mission and that
keep us on point and motivated for doing
what we do here at the children's gmp
so
we have a very large impact here at the
hospital in that a lot of the products
that are coming out of the research and
development side
are considered orphan products and they
would typically not find
any interest
in large pharmaceutical companies just
because the
the scope or the the number
of prospective patients is too small for
them to make that sort of investment so
it was decided
that
we would build our own children's gmp
here on site and we
at the time were the first
pediatric cancer children's hospital
that is
to build our gnp on site
so
some of the achievements and milestones
at our hospital include
the cure of hemophilia b using an aav
gene therapy approach that was published
in 2014
and
i did want to make a mention that we
don't only treat pediatric cancer but we
also are involved in other
collaborations throughout the world with
treating uh diseases that affect not
only children but also adults so
we also are a part of the world health
organizations we're a center of
excellence for the world health
organization for monitoring and
and coming up with seed stocks for bird
flu to to prevent avian pandemics
and then as you see here we've also had
collaborations uh with patients in
england for treating hemophilia b so
even though our focus is
pediatric cancer we have our our
in our research hands involved in a lot
of different
products that we manufacture here
another advanced include the cure of
bubble boy disease using the lentivirus
based approach which was published in
2019 essentially
we were able to
reconstitute
a child's immune system where
you know children are born without
immune systems and so we were able to
treat them using the lentivirus therapy
and and
basically generate
a new immune system for them
uh in 2021 we published a study about
treating children with neuroblastoma
with one of the antibodies that we
manufacture here at the gmp and so
using a combined
chemotherapy monoclonal antibody
approach we were able to significantly
reduce the mortality rate
i.e the three-year survival rate of
these children who had
these neuroblastomas and were not
responding well to to just the
chemotherapy alone
um and then of course you know back in
the 60s we started with
acute
uh with a cl leukemia cancers in the 60s
where there was about a 6
survival rate and we have that survival
rate all the way up to around 95 percent
now so we've made a lot of progress in
the last 50 plus years
all right so with the background taken
care of let's talk about
the agenda for today for today's talk
first we're going to go into a little
bit about what a lentivar virus back
what does the lindy virus look like
what are the platform methods that
we're going to look at today that will
allow us to analyze these antivirus
products which
we'll talk about today which includes
the lentivirus protium analysis so we're
going to discuss the tighter
determination
by analyzing the p24 protein
we're also going to look at lentivirus
protein profiling as well as the genome
analysis
by and and within the genome analysis
we'll be able to look at the the size of
the genome within the latin virus as
well as evaluate the purity of the
product
and then we'll finish with a summary
so
lentivirus vectors lentivirus vectors
are essentially
a family of viruses that include that
have single
rna in there
and they've been used for a numerous
number of applications for for
delivering genes and stably delivering
genes into patients
that have been affected by a various
number of diseases
so some of the advantages of using these
viruses include
transdu your ability to transduce not
only
non-dividing cells but dividing cells as
well
you can con you can accommodate large
trans genes all the way up to 10
kilobases unlike the adeno
the
aav viruses which where you're limited
to
genes
that are less than two kilobases
there's low immunogenicity associated
with these viruses
there's a broad tropism
for the viruses so you're able to infect
a multitude of different cell types
within the body
uh we also observe long-term robust
transgene expression both in vitro and
in vivo so
these viruses do stability integrate
into the genomes of the of the host
you can accommodate not only a single
transgene but you can you can express
and stably integrate multiple trans
genes
uh you're able to integrate with it
again as i mentioned you're you're able
to integrate into the host genome
and that
integration uh persists
beyond
uh
it is uh it is stable so that when cells
divide
you maintain the presence of that
transgene
and then last but not least it's stable
ex vivo
so some of the applications include
introducing new genes
for example like
introducing the gamma gene into
patients that have this bubble boy
disease
silencing of gene expression using
the delivery of single hairpin rnas
delivery of tumor-specific
t-cell receptors so that you can
hone in and have your immune system go
after
tumor tumor-specific antigens
and then also uh the delivery of
chimeric antigen receptors where you're
where you're stably transfecting
the t cells and and targeting the tumors
via these kite
these chimeric antigen receptors that
are on the t cells which will allow them
to recognize the tumor cells
so the proteum of the linear virus
comprised
is comprised of five important
structures
and some non-structural proteins all of
them play important roles in the life of
the cycle of the linear virus for
example the envelope for the envelope
proteins the glycoprotein complexes
enable the virus to attach and diffuse
the target cells and initiate the
infectious cycle
for the capsule proteins the
quantification of the p24 protein is
usually used for linear virus
tighter determination
so here we've developed a separation
based on the method
separation based method for lay virus
protein analysis with two purposes first
to provide the accurate tighter
tighter determination in the length of
our sample
based on quantitative a separate
separated p24 capsule protein without
any interference of the other proteins
in the sample at the same time the
well-separated protein file profile
could be utilized
for linear viral protein
security assessment
so first we'll look at tighter
determination by evaluating
the p by correlating p 24 protein to the
titer
of the linear virus
so the work the workflow started with an
easy and efficient two-step sample
preparation protocol which included
disassembly of the linear virus
particles using sts
and then covalent attachment of a 404 to
the to the virus particles
or to the disassembled proteins
labeling the proteins and making them
fluorescent
the resulting perillium dye tagged
loading virus protium is then loaded
onto the pa 800
plus pharmaceutical analysis system
which is what we have here at st jude or
you can load those onto other ce systems
the resulting electroferograms is shown
in the figure on the right
over here
so you can see you get a whole array of
different proteins alluding in the
electroparagraph
essentially
in this electrophorogram there are over
20 20 proteins
in this lentivirus protein profile the
peak corresponding to the p24 protein
is determined by spiking the linear
virus sample with a commercially
available p24 standard
in the figure on the left the trace on
the bottom is the original
separation trace of the linear sample
with the concentration about
one times ten to the ninth trans uh
transducing units per mil to use per mil
while the six traces above the bottom
one are
the same linear virus sample with spiked
spiked in with increasing amounts of the
standard
the conclusion that we can draw from the
figure on the left are
the peaks in a circle with increasing
area along the
increasing p24 spiked in is identified
as p24 so essentially the spike protein
allowed us so they identify
the p24 protein within our sample
we also can see that there's excellent
reproducibility of the protein profile
if we look at the other separated peaks
and the electroprograms even the various
amounts of p24 in the samples
proving that the qualitative
excusing the quantitative variation of
the p24 protein content did not affect
profiling
repeatability
the resulting profile can be readily
used for batch device dibatch
reproducibility and protein purity
assessment of the lenny virus samples
also by plotting the plot
by plotting the peak area of the
identified p24p versus the amount of p24
spiked in we could get a plot with very
good linearity
as you can see the r squared value
is
well above 0.99
let's move on to the next slide here
looks like we have two of the same
slides
so here in this slide we're evaluating
the linear
linearity and the loq
of the standard
so this p24 standard was used to
evaluate the linearity and determine the
loq
of this workflow by injecting increasing
amounts of standalone p24 standard
on into the p8
p800 plus system with the cds cests
chemistry
so the figure on the left
is the overhead traces of the p24 peaks
with two fold serial dilutions and the
figure on the right is the corresponding
linearity plot
impressively the plot covers three
orders of magnitude and we
determine the yellow q to be around
eight nanograms per ml for the p24
standard
so what does the precision look like for
injections injection to injection
repeatability
for six consecutive injections of linear
virus sample the relative standard
deviation
of the migration time and the peak areas
are less than 0.2 percent
and 0.91
respectively
so precision is excellent between
injections of the same sample
so how about from batch to batch that is
from one day to the next how well what
does the position look like there
for six independent sample preps the
relative standard deviation of the
migration time and p carries are no more
than one percent
and five percent respectively so
the person rsv is still quite
satisfactory
the figure on the left is an example of
the overlay p24 scanner with different
concentrations from a single preparation
figure on the right is the average of
the standard curves
prepared and analyzed from three
different days with the corresponding
ear bars on each
point so you can see from three separate
days that we're still getting excellent
reproducibility between preparations
of the p24 sample
the quantity of the p24 protein of a
lengthy of our sample is determined
using the average standard curve that
was shown in the previous slide
after converting the p24 quantitation or
that is the p-curious to lentivirus
titer the titer of the linear parse
sample is found to be 1.45 1.45 1.46
times 10 to the ninth to use per ml or
transduction units per ml
as was measured on three different days
so we have very consistent results
the numbers are consistent with the
values obtained from the vendor
uh as well which uh the vendor obtained
their tu data by using the elisa assay
so this is a basically a comparable
method
to the elisa method that they used
so next we're going to look at venti
vector protein profiling that is what
what does the protium look like
in an electrophorogram
for the lentivirus vector
so
in this in this chart what we're looking
at is the
at the top electroferogram trace you see
the lv
gfp
that's the commercial standard that was
and then the following five samples are
dilute they're called the loot dilute
samples and those samples were provided
from our process development group here
at st jude for
abcx to look at
so
what you can see here is that p24 has
been identified
in both
the commercial it's known it's known
where it dilutes so by using the
commercial
uh vector we're able to identify p24 and
the vsvg protein within our samples here
from saint jude
so in this slide you can see there's a
very strong correlation between
the peak areas
for the p24
protein as well as the psg vsc
g proteins and you would expect to see
this sort of correlation
when you effectively
uh remove the free p24 during sample
prep if there was any free p24 in the
solution
that could distort or
cause that correlation to go away so
this indicates that
there there is no freaky 24
uh
or that it's been eliminated from uh
from the profile during the sample prep
step
and the last thing we're going to look
at is genome sizing and impurity
screening that is
what does the genome the rna look like
from these antivirus vectors and what
sort of impurities can we see that is
nucleic acid types of impurities
when we uh
when we evaluate the the nucleic acid
content
so why would we want to look at
linear virus genome what would what
would be the importance when we're
manufacturing
antiviruses what's what's
what sort of quality attribute is
important um
for us well knowing knowing first of all
that we actually have it you know the
genome in there is critical because this
is what's ultimately what has allowed
the transgene to be passed on to the
cells
so it's it's it's important to know that
we have full-length
genomes within the cells
and so you could there are situations
where you could you could have
incomplete rna transgenes at the three
prime end
and that could lead to failed reverse
transcription in target cells and thus
reduce transfection or transduction
efficiency
linear of our linear viral vector genome
integrity is one of the critical quality
attributes too so like i've seen we need
to make sure that we are we have a
sufficient number
of intact genomes so that we can have
transduction of the transgenes
also
we like to be able to evaluate residual
host cell
dna and our rna
and you know with those sort of residual
nucleic acids being present you could
have increases in the risk for immune
responses so
purity and purity is critical for these
preparations as well as evaluating
the ratio of empty particles to full
particles so that's
absolutely critical that we know
that our genomes are high
quality so this slide shows the works
the workflow for genome integrity
analysis
first the nucleic acids are extracted
from the samples and then analyzed on
the ce systems which could be either the
biophase ad800 system or the p p8800
system from abc's
results are shown in electroparagrams in
the pedal on the right
which we'll get into more detail on the
next slide in this sample the intact
genome for the
size
is has been determined to be around 6.1
kb
and is well separated from the partial
genome and other impurities
so this slide shows the results obtained
for the analysis of four c
four research-grade
linear viruses
with different genome sizes from the
commercial vendor
each
virus sample
has a vault had a volume of 25
microliters and the titer was 189
transducing units per ml
so we tried to extract equivalent
amounts of transducing units per sample
peaks of the intact genomes are
indicated by the arrows
rna ladders are shown at the bottom as
the bottom two traces both in the pink
trace and the orange trace at the bottom
so you can use those traces too to size
the actual size of the genome
this slide shows the assay repeatability
results obtained with 12 injections of
the lv cherry sample which is shown in
the left panel
and the lv
dfp sample shown in the right panel
peak profiles and migration times are
very consistent between the injections
the rsc for the migration time for the
intact genome peaks was less than 0.5
for both
of the samples
so back to the samples that were
obtained from saint jude from our gmp
so this this result shows results
obtained for these
samples were injected with a pressure
injection and separated at a capillary
temperature
of 30 degrees celsius so
uh
with these samples the
the
amount of sample produced per sample
the number of transition units would not
normalize so you we would expect to see
different
genome sizes
and the only thing worth pointing out is
that you can see there is some
variability in the intact genome in
terms of the peak shape so
what that means
functionally in terms of how well
each preparation transduces the cells is
not currently now
so this slide shows results obtained in
an in-depth analysis of the genome
integrity of the lvgsp sample from the
commercial vendor
the top panel shows the control results
obtained without treatment of the sample
before
nucleic acid extraction the middle panel
those results obtained when the samples
were treated with either benzenes
or dnase one before the the samples
before the nucleic acid was extracted so
benzenes is a is a more non-specific
nucleus that will cleave both any any
sort of form of rna or dna versus the
dnase one will be
is much more specific for dna
so
the fact that
this
that both
the fact that those impurities that
you're observing in the top trace are no
longer present after after treatment
with benzenes or dna's one
indicates these these are
nucleic acid impurities that were
present outside of the virus
and and in the two bottom traces you can
see that the benzodiazepine
sample and the dna's treated sample
look very similar indicating
that there's probably no contamination
with rna because if there was
you would have seen rna persist in the
dnase one treated sample
and in which case the
would look slightly different
and have most likely a
significant number more of impurities
rna impurities
all right so
in conclusion the ce platform technology
demonstrates unique capabilities for
quality attributes
monitoring of lentivirus vectors
we've shown that there's a sense there's
a sensitive type sensitive tighter
determination based on the precise
quantification of p24 proteins
with a four
magnitude orders of detection linearity
and an r square greater than 0.99
and an lq loq of eight nanograms per ml
with using this method it's easy to
assess batch to battery for disability
in terms of titers as well as protein
purities
based on the evaluation of the resulting
protein profile that we showed
we also observe a linear relationship
between p24 and the vsct proteins
indicating that the ce titer method is
not measuring
uh free p24
which is good
uh free put as i stated before free p24
could confound results
the high sensitivity of the celaf
enables
genome integrity analysis of the linear
viral vectors at a titer of
one e9 to use per mil without any sort
of amplification step
providing high resolution of intact
linear virus genomes from various
impurities with very good
re repeatability
so
so thank you very much for your time if
you made it all the way to the end uh
thank you for sticking with me
uh if there's any questions or
you know you would like to
you know if you had anything that you
wanted to clarify you wanted me to
clarify please feel free to ask now
i'm available
thank you aaron for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
the ce method produced results similar
to the elisa method what advantages are
there to analyzing lentiviral samples by
ce
um
i think one of the main advantages if
you look at the
the range of the linear range of
quantification you have about three
for ce it spans around three orders of
magnitude so you
your linear range goes from around eight
nanograms per ml all the way up to
eighteen hundred nanograms per ml
so you're working with a much larger
range which would
mean you wouldn't have to
uh you know look at trying to
do multiple dilutions to try to figure
out what you know what concentration you
should put your your test sample at so
you have a much larger uh range
for the ce method as compared to the
elisa method
got about 100 fold or
uh three or two orders of magnitude
range and linearity for the elisa method
so
that that range of quantification is
more limited for elisa
um
in terms of sensitivity the ce methods
got you know as i mentioned
an lq of around 8 nanograms per ml
versus around
4.6
picograms per ml for the elysius so the
elisa is a more sensitive method
but it the range is more limited so also
in terms of
sample preparation time it's only about
you're only looking around 30 minutes to
prepare your samples
for the ce method
you're basically going to be doing
a buffer exchange into the matrix that's
used
to be uh for is analyzed on the ce
method
versus you've got multiple washes with
antibodies and an amplification step
with the elisa so that's going to be
around 90 minutes so just
the front end sample preparation time is
shorter
for ce uh
in terms of throughput
you know with eliza you're going to have
a higher throughput
because you've you can you know
scan a 96 well plate relatively quickly
but with ce
uh you're going to you know again you're
looking at probably around 50 to 60
minutes per sample for analysis
so
does that answer the question
i i believe so
so let's see our next question is
the protein profiling method
demonstrated a linear correlation
between the p24 protein and the vsvg
protein is this an attribute that you
will track in your process
so i spoke with my
process development director who is in
charge of manufacturing or
developing a lot of scaling up processes
for manufacturing or lending virus
vectors and he said that there's quite a
bit of variability in the vsvg
expression
between
perhaps
so that
it doesn't always correlate from batch
to batch you know you don't always have
that same one-to-one relationship or
linear relationship so but currently
we're not using that
in our in terms of using it as a quality
attribute for our products that we're
manufacturing right now lentivirus
products
all right thank you
next question
the intact genome assessment reported a
wide range of encapsulated rna in the
lentiviral particle
will this workflow be used to optimize
manufacturing conditions
i think this method actually holds a lot
of problems we're just we are not
currently using it it is this is a
rather novel method actually so
we're going to need to
further evaluate
whether there's a really correlation
between
the genome content and the actual
infectious tires so
i think we would
need to make several standard curves
from different batches and then
calculate
infectious tires
using the the nucleic acid p carry
as a as a way to back calculate that
all right thank you
next question
was the initial titer determined via
elisa and this method being the
secondary proof of it or is it strictly
a ce method overall
so if you look at the presentation you
can see
that the plot has peak area of p24
versus the concentration of p24 protein
micrograms per ml
so
in order to go from micrograms per ml to
tighter you would use that conversion
factor
so
basically one nanogram of p24 is
equivalent to 1.25 times 10 to the
seventh lengthy virus particles
we double check with painting on this we
generated this data in our corporation
but i believe that was a direct
conversion from
the micrograms to
virus particles not actually using
the p24 tighter data from the
manufacturer as a way to get that total
partial account
so that would you need we need to double
check
all right thank you
next question
is the same matrix used for protein and
rna separation
our i guess we need any clarification do
you mean the matrix in terms of the the
gel that's inside the capillary or how
we treat the samples is it are you
talking about the matrix inside the
capillary i want to clarify that
um i'm not sure
maybe hopefully the person that
submitted this question will um
follow up
um
let's
go ahead
yeah let's just assume we're talking i
mean i'm going to assume that he's
talking about what
actual capillary or analysis method
we're using and the answer would be yes
it's a
it's an uncoded capillary that has the
gel matrix inside of it and that's used
for both rna and protein analysis
as far as if that's what he's been
referring to or the person's referring
to
okay
all right thank you
uh yes kevin yes inside the capillary
yep that would be a yes all right great
um
next question
what is the signal to noise ratio for
the loq
i did not calculate that so i can't i
can't give you an answer for that
okay
and
um the next question why is the genome
not affected by benzonase or dna's
treatment
it's protected
encapsulated within the virus so it
would not be anything only only residual
rna or dna outside of the virus will be
impacted by uh treatment with those two
enzymes
all right
well we will wrap up with that final
question thank you again aaron for your
time today in your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor psyx for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
you